Hello. Hi. Hello. Welcome to SmartList. We just want everyone to know that we got so lucky that we interviewed Kamala Harris the day before she was announced on the ticket as a vice presidential candidate with Joe Biden. So we interviewed her on Monday, the 10th.
She was put on the ticket on the 11th. The interview you're about to hear, I guess, would be the last interview she did before she was put on the ticket, right, guys? 24 hours before it was announced, right? Yeah. She was put on the ticket and hot off the presses and you will see how incredibly fun and funny she is. Here it comes.
SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. Gentlemen, good day. Good day. Today is a good day.
Are you guys a little, I'm a little nervous about, this is, I've told you guys who this guest is because I didn't want you guys to... You broke protocol. Well, I wanted us to get our nerves out of the way first because while we've had some very big guests on the show, you look, you look ready. Okay, good. Yeah. I want to impress her.
So I don't expect you guys to be fully prepared. I've got some softball questions. I've got a couple of hard hitters. We're going to figure out kind of what the vibe is, but I just, and this is a big week, a big week for her and our country. So I'm just, I'm stunned that she said yes, and I'm glad that she hasn't gotten a phone call yet this morning where she needs to cancel because as we will repeat when we're talking to her, today is Monday, August 10th, and we may find out today who is on the ticket.
With Giovanna. Could be her. So... Did you ever, Jason, want to, any part of you want to or still want to be a public servant of any kind or run for anything? Because I think you'd be really good. Or a private servant. Would you be, would you consider being a private servant?
Well, what's the rate? What's, how long's the drive? Where do you guys live? Pretty close to you. You know where I live. Okay. Sure. I guess.
Can I have nights off? Let's see how it goes. Yeah. I don't really aspire to a public office, but... What about you, Will? Would I ever consider being prime minister of Canada? Yeah. Yeah.
Would they elect me? Sure. Okay. Let me ask you a question. What's the capital of... Judicious. Of Iran. Tehran.
So, listen. What's the capital of Germany? The capital of Germany is now Berlin. West Germany used to be Bonn. You're an idiot. You're an idiot. Spell Bonn. You're so dumb.
B-O-N-N. True story. Where's the umlat? There is none. Where's the ox on a goo? That's French. Any more questions? I mean, this is...
Yeah. Is batting a thousand a good average? I gave you the easiest damn... That's true. That's true. That's pretty good. And it is true also about Bonn, anyway. Yeah.
Yeah, no, no, no. Well, you know, it's a perfect time to bring on somebody who can actually answer all of our questions about all of this. Yes. Good idea, Sean. Okay. Gentlemen, without any further ado, Senator Kamala Harris. Yes.
Yes. It's so cool. This is the first time I've clapped. I'm gonna clap too. The first time I've clapped on the podcast, hi. I think you're right. We're so excited that you said, yes, my God. So honored.
There must be nothing going on for you to say yes to doing this podcast. It's intense. It's really intense, Jason. I mean, people are suffering out there. People are suffering. Yeah. You know, I met you one time a while ago. You're so wonderful to have like a special intimate evening at some place.
I don't know where it was. Really special for you, I guess. Yeah. You don't even remember where it was. Well, it was like a hidden location. It was a shot. You were so eloquent and so well-spoken and so intelligent. It was just incredible to hear you speak.
And I walked up to you afterwards and I had, you're like, so if anybody has any ideas, of course, my ideas are horrible. And I walked up to you and your assistant was like, I'm sorry, Ms. Senator Harris has, she has somewhere to be right now. So if you could make a quick, I go, no, no, no, I'm busier. I'm gonna leave first. I have to go first. I'm much busier than she is.
As a matter of fact, I'm gonna end this conversation and leave first. I have to go. Yeah. Yeah. You don't want to be the last one in the room. No. Ever. Ever.
What was your idea, Sean? It sounds like it was a great idea. It was so bad. I can't. It's embarrassing. Only blue M&Ms. Well, red, white and blue. Red, white and blue.
There you go. There you go. So we usually don't know when we're going to air certain episodes, that there's smarter people in our group that make those decisions, but obviously we're going to air this as soon as we can. Listener, we are recording this on August 10th, today is Monday. And there's this thing that Trump was talking about yesterday about his executive order and stuff like that.
And without getting into all the weeds of that, it seems to me that as brief as his executive order was, there were still obviously some salient points in there that all of you guys need to understand, read, digest. Who does that? How can you possibly read every single thing that you need to know about so that no crafty sort of like in the small print gets pushed through something that you guys might say yes to? So like, is there a huge staff of readers that then break it all down for you guys?
Is that my choice? No, you're absolutely right. And some of these bill, now what Trump did is not a bill. It's an executive order. It's basically a memo. And so there's a whole issue with that in terms of the legal effect of what he's done and does he actually constitutionally have the power to do what he did. But putting that aside in bills, you're right.
I mean, they can be thousands of pages sometimes and the details matter every time. So yes, there are staffs of very smart people who are familiar with the language, familiar with how a word will be interpreted based on how it's always been interpreted. And they will work around the clock scanning through and actually reading through each of those documents. But sometimes the loopholes are well disguised. And so you could see in the PPP, for example, so in the Paycheck Protection Program that we instituted that was intended to give relief to small businesses and so many small businesses,
real small businesses did not get the benefit of it because they don't have the relationship with the fancy banker, right? They're not on a first name basis with the banker. They may go to a community bank. They don't have lines of credit and 90% actually of minority and small women owned businesses did not get the benefit of the PPP for that very reason. So the details do matter and what we try to do certainly and what I try to do is when we have figured out that there's a hole in it or a loophole, fix it for the next time.
And you must, your years obviously as an attorney, as a prosecutor, helped you that that's what you do, right? You kind of on the fly have to look at stuff and Jason, it befuddles him. It took him three days to, when he guest starred on Silver Spoons, to get through a 30 years. Yeah. These are tough. It's left to right, top to bottom, right? Is the way that the reading goes, right?
But it's not just that you have to digest it, but you really have to take it in and really take a position and understand what it is and what the implications are of every specific point on a micro and macro simultaneously, all these things. I mean, these are, and these are big issues. These aren't just little sort of trivial. These are life and death, especially like you were saying for small businesses, et cetera. This is make or break moments right now. You're totally right.
So for example, okay, so for example, the issue of the United States Postal Service, right? As you guys may have heard, that's one of the biggest issues right now that is weighing on people, which is that this administration is basically cutting the budget of the United States Postal Service. So what does that mean? So I actually sent out a question to all of my Twitter followers and online folks and I said, tell me how, if you own a small business, how is this impacting you?
Whoa. Yeah. These small businesses, they have a product that they sell and they ship it out and they say, promise you overnight delivery. It's not getting there overnight, right? So then what ends up happening? Their Yelp score starts going down because people are like, they say it's going to be overnight, but it's not.
Don't get this product, right? Right. They end up having to pay reimbursement for people or late fees. All of this, not of their doing. So it is hurting. I mean, tragically hurting small businesses. In real time. In real time.
In real time. While we're supposed to be propping up the economy in small businesses. So the reason that they're using the Postal Service is because it is not free, but ostensibly cheaper than some of the private carriers, the FedEx, the UPS, the DHL. Right, of course. And Jason, historically reliable and historically reliable. I mean, this is one of the great public institutions we have is the Postal Service, where everyone, regardless of your income, has a guaranteed access to communication and to commerce.
Not based on how much money you have, but you know, everyone is charged the same rate. And it's sort of the cynical view that I've taken the last couple of days. Amongst other people, I'm not alone in this is that, of course, at the root of this, at the heart of this is, I love the argument that the Postal Service loses X million dollars a year. Well, yeah, of course, it's not there. You know, my kids cost me money, my friend was saying he treated me the other day, my kids cost me money, but I don't get rid of them.
You know, that's the price of doing this is what we do, it's a service that's provided to me. It's not a profit department. Yes, I'm right. And it's part of our democracy. It's what we... And it's part of our democracy and the ability for people to transact, people who don't have the same...
Yeah. ...in the same way the moms... But also that the cynical point I was going to say was that this is just another arm or tentacle of voter suppression, ultimately. Yeah, yeah, for sure. ...or brazen one, it's not even subtle. Yeah, that's what they say, Jason, it's not even like subtle. It's like...
I mean, yeah, so here's the thing, I'm always welcoming anybody, including, of course, the private sector that wants to step up and support our democracy in any way possible. But I also believe that there are certain essential government functions that should not be privatized. And one of them is the Postal Service. The others are public education, public health, and public safety. They should just not be privatized. We do not want people to have a profit motive in order to deliver basic and essential services
to the American people. Yeah. Because if you attach a profit motive, you will see that those who have will do better, and those who do not have will do worse. So that's where I go. You know, so when he's doing stuff like this, I'm sure like everyone else sits there and thinks, A, why do we have to take it? Is there some sort of countermeasure that we can do absent waiting until November?
Like, can we even make it there? And the first thing that comes to mind is this 25th Amendment thing that was floated around a while ago. And I just wonder, what else would need to be on the plate for whomever exercises the 25th Amendment? I believe it's Cabinet. What else do they need to see? He's disassembling these federal departments, there's this outrageous economic disaster,
he's committing this political suicide for himself, for his party, and obviously overseeing the death of what, like one American a minute. So what else would you write in some horrible fantasy about what would need to be on the plate that would motivate a 25th Amendment? I just don't get it. I mean, listen, I think what you're speaking to are what we designed as the checks and balances in our government so that where there was abuse of power by any one branch, there would be a commensurate check on that abuse of power.
One could argue, though, that we have been in the midst of a constitutional crisis in that those checks and balances have not been reinforced, meaning that we have seen abject abuse of power by the executive branch and this president, Donald Trump. But Congress as a whole has not held him accountable because it takes both the House and the Senate to do a lot of the things that actually would enforce that accountability. And right now, the Senate is run by a bunch of folks who are doing his bidding. And so that's why I really do go to the point of the election, which is in less than three months.
But we're going to lose another 150,000 people by then. But this is where the accountability also rests in, I think, the greatest power in our country, which is the people. The people. And the people have great power. And I think they always are ultimately the check on an imbalance or an abuse of power within our systems. And so that means getting people registered to vote.
It means emphasizing early voting because I am concerned about the manipulation of the U.S. Postal Service. We don't want ballots being counted weeks after the election because it's predictable that this guy will create incredible chaos. Look, there are going to be a lot of obstacles. Let's start with the fact that the United States Supreme Court in 2013 gutted the Voting Rights Act and took the teeth out of it, the teeth that were in place to track states that had a history of suppressing the vote, in particular the black vote.
And what happened after 2013 is in at least two dozen states, the state legislatures put in place rules that were about suppressing or deterring people of color, students, indigenous voters from actually voting. So that obstacle is here. I serve on the Senate Intelligence Committee. Believe me, and the United States Intelligence Community, Russia interfered in the election of the president of the United States in 2016, and they will do it again. They are doing it, right?
Can I ask you a question? So, you know, we talk about voter suppression and ultimately, and I know that it is across all people of color affected by it, but ultimately we're talking about suppressing the black vote. Ultimately, that's the biggest percentage, right? That seems to be, that's where the target is for the Republican Party at large. And the Russians. The Intelligence Community's investigations showed us that the Russians also targeted
black voters. Are they doing that in order to aid Trump and or whomever it is and or Republicans in the Senate because it's much more advantageous to them to have? Or is it just an ideological difference? So here's the problem that I see, and overall it is this. The government was designed to be there in particular when the people are in need to support them and lift them up and carry them through moments of crisis like this. And there has been an abject failure.
You can look at it across the board. You look at it with a president who from the beginning called the coronavirus a hoax and muzzled public health professionals and did not put in place the Defense Production Act to make sure that we would have U.S. manufacturing of everything from masks to ventilators. You can look at it when the president has his attorney, Bill Barr, who's supposed to be the people's attorney, the attorney general, in court right now trying to get rid of the Affordable Care Act that will, when they get rid of it, take away health care from over 20 million people in the midst of a public health crisis.
Not to mention the evictions. Right. And so, I mean, these are the reasons I say that we have to really see that right now the American people need their government to work. They need an extension of unemployment benefits. Democrats have been fighting for this. Well, 30 million people right now are on unemployment either because they are unemployed or underemployed.
Why do I say underemployed? Because we have a lot of people in our country right now, a lot of people who work two and three jobs on a regular basis. Yeah, it's not. We have to elect Joe Biden the next president of the United States. Yeah, of course. Of course, of course. It's a gun deal.
And we have to do that for so many reasons that are about, one, correcting course around the economy, around the public health crisis, but also restoring some integrity to our government and its highest offices. Do you think there's the threat of complacency among voters? Because the Republicans are saying that there's voter suppression. The Democrats are saying the post office is going to be, you know, corrupt. Both sides are kind of saying this is so much as against us. Why bother go out and vote?
Do you think there's a lot of that and how do we combat that? We have to believe in the power and the beauty of our democracy and our country and the ideals upon which we were founded. I will tell you, my motivation always is not to fight against something. It's to fight for something, to fight for the strength of who we are and the ideals of who we are. Right. And I just want to go back to Will's point for a second.
Well, correct me if I'm wrong, but I feel like the broader point, and I'd love to hear your opinion on this. You're correct to me because I'm Canadian. Okay. Would you agree that the big difference between Republicans and Democrats, sort of their ideology about government and what it should be doing, that Democrats, and this is to overly simplify everything, Democrats sort of feel that government is there to help people. The Republicans feel that government is there as potentially a tool for business.
And simply there's just a difference in ideology. And that's why it's hard to find the middle ground. Is that what you find mostly when you're negotiating between sides? I'll say this. You know, there are good Republicans, there are bad Democrats. Okay. So I'm not going to paint everyone with a broad brush, but this is what I will say. Democrats as a general matter believe that government should be robust enough to, yes,
help people who are in need and to uplift the American people. And you look by contrast at some of the hypocrisy around generally what has been some rhetoric from the Republican Party. For example, they'll always talk about deficits. And if you track every presidential administration, it has been the Republican administrations that have built up the deficit, not Democratic administrations. For example, even in this administration, they passed a tax bill, guys, benefiting the top 1% in the biggest corporations of America.
And it's going to contribute, it's estimated $1 trillion to the deficit for the richest people who don't need it. Meanwhile, in America, even before this pandemic, in 99% of the counties in America, if you are a minimum wage worker working full-time, you cannot afford market rate for a one-bedroom apartment. Look at where we are in the midst of this coronavirus, where it's estimated over the next month, 20 million renters will not be able to pay their rent, 15 million homeowners will not be able to pay their mortgage.
And so what we're looking at is the difference of opinion, because what I have seen out of the Republican Party, since I've been in the Senate these last three and a half years, is it's all about deregulation. It's about taking away the teeth from the EPA, which is about saying, let's bring down greenhouse gas emissions, because guess what? We all need to breathe clean air. It's been about deregulation of industries, including coal and oil, again, same point, right?
It has been about putting Betsy DeVos, are you kidding me, in the Secretary of Education? And to continue to try and privatize education, as opposed to invest in our children. And when we, as Democrats, talk about it, it's not about cost, it's about investment. You want to look at our friends in the private sector, you know those who are most successful? The ones who don't ask what's it going to cost, they ask, what is the return on my investment? Right. That's how Democrats think.
What's the return on the investment? If you invest in the American people, you will win every day of the week. Jason brought up this idea of this, or the ideological divide, and what is that demand? First of all, I think that that's true, that that used to be what it is, but the Republicans have played the greatest trick, which I always talk about, or think about, which is, first of all, they always talk about a small government, and people don't know what they're talking about. You asked somebody on the street, well, yeah, I vote for Republicans, I want a small government.
You don't know what you're talking about. George W. Bush had the biggest government in the history of this country, and yet he, he claimed that that's what he wanted. Okay. So then you have, what they, what they managed to do is consistently convince the people who will benefit the least from these programs, from their, from them being empowered to vote for them, people who are going to suffer, people who aren't going to be able to receive any benefits, and all these things, and they've consistently convinced these people along
different lines, and the people that, that are doing it, they've, this conservative movement that started, what, 45 years ago, this, this, this sort of handful of guys. This is a concerted effort that's been going on for a few generations to, to get to the point where we're at today. And again, it's a very sort of dystopian view that these guys, or that, that we're kind of living in now where they have created this, the, the gap has never been greater between the haves and the have nots. That's right.
And, and it's all by design. That's what's so scary. All of it's by design. Trump is just doing a bidding of the guys like the Sheldon Adelson's and all these guys. This is by design, and that's what's scary, and that's what people in this country need to be afraid of. And the people of this country need to really ask the question which they do every day, and I think this election is going to give them the answer.
Who is standing by working people in America? Working people. People who work hard every day if they're working one job or three jobs. People who just want others to recognize the dignity of their work and their labor. People who just want to know if I work hard and I, and I do the right thing, am I going to be able to keep a roof over my head and not worry about it? Am I going to be able to feed my kids and not worry about it? Am I going to be able to take a vacation once a year and, and, and whatever.
And just standing by working people. How do you do that? You have affordable childcare. You have paid family leave. You do not try to destroy organized labor, but you support organized labor and collective bargaining. Right. You support a public education system and fund it instead of right now, which is that
public teachers, when school was, you know, in normal session, two thirds were coming out of their own back pocket to help pay for school supplies. Yeah. Right? Can I ask a question about California because we all live in it and it's, correct me, it's the third largest economy, what, in the world? It's about fifth. Yeah.
Fifth. Okay. Fifth. And, and so I keep reading about, you know, every year in California, there's a drought. There's a drought. There's a drought. There's a drought in California, fifth largest economy. When are we going to figure out how to desalinate water or whatever so that every year there's
not like this crazy shortage and these articles I'm reading about water is the next thing for these business people. I'm so glad you brought this up and listen, this is one of my big, big, big areas of concern water. Okay. So here to your point, for generations, wars were fought over oil. In a matter of years, wars will be fought over water. Yeah.
So let's do something. You're a menacing resource as a daughter of California, having gone through many droughts. I've experienced this thing personally, but to your point, we need to have water policy that invests in the storage of water, right? The capture of water, desalination, recycling, conservation, and to do these things is to be smart and guess what the other thing about it is? To do a lot of that, it requires building up the infrastructure around it for capturing storage.
That's jobs. Yeah, right. That's the creation of jobs. Plumbers. That's the building trades jobs. That's carpenters. That's bricklayers. That's all of the folks who actually can do the work that is about also protecting our
environment and a diminishing resource, which is water. Yeah, because I'm kind of an idiot if you haven't gathered, and I'm looking to my left where the beach is, and I'm like, wait, most of the earth is water. Let's figure this out, people. This was this weekend that you realized that, right? Yeah, I'm exhausted. So all of these great ideas, and I say great because I'm not smart enough to think of a more exciting term like the whole water issue.
If we are fortunate enough to hold on to the House, win the White House, and take the Senate, can we unilaterally do all of these great common sense things? Can we do anything we want? Here's the thing that I hope. I hope that we don't have to do it alone. So many of these issues are issues that impact everyone, and they really at their core, not even bipartisan or nonpartisan. What we need to do to build back up our economy and invest in infrastructure, right?
America's infrastructure is 125, 150 years old. Everybody will benefit from building back up our infrastructure, and that's a ton of jobs. In fact, Joe Biden has great policies around that. What we need to do around investment in our public schools, listen, our babies K-12 could give, you know what, who we voted for in the last election. They just want to be able to go to school when we can get past this pandemic in particular and get an education that allows them to reach the capacity that they're God-given talents.
These are the things that I hope we can actually agree on in a bipartisan way and put aside the ideology and just get to fixing some of these problems that are really practical. Are you guys testing yet at the Senate? You guys don't have testing, do you? You're right. We don't have a system for testing. Why is that? Well, because guess what?
The administration doesn't have a national system for testing. It's all, you know, let's start there. We need to have a national system for testing. We need to have a national system for contact tracing. But you would think that you guys being a, you know, a vital and essential group of workers in this country to say the least, you would think that the House and the Senate would have testing at least once a week free and available to you guys. There's got to be a reason why you guys said, no, we're not going to do that.
I mean, I wasn't a part of that decision, but I'll tell you this. I do feel that members of Congress shouldn't get the benefit of something before the American people get it. And on this subject, the president should follow through on a statement he made months ago, which is everyone who wants the test can get it, because that's just not the case in America right now. And that's why we see these surges. And also we need immediate test, right?
So that you actually get the result within hours of taking the test because getting it seven and 10 days later, it does no one any good because you're exposed to the virus even if you were negative at the time you took the test. I want to switch gears a little bit. What is fame like for you? I would imagine that your, your times to the grocery store have been easier in years past. Are you still doing your own marketing? Yes.
You are? Oh yeah. You're not going to 24 hour fitness to do your workouts, right? Well, nobody can anymore. All the gym shut down. You want to know what I did doing the virus? I got a little fold up bike and then I was using water bottles as my weight. Well, you need to stock those water bottles.
But how do you, how do you enjoy that? I love people. I love people. But it can be, you know, everybody's got a camera on their phone. And so when you're out, did they all line up to take pictures and how do you, do you have a method, a strategy to be polite yet keep going? I want to see you getting a fight with a no-masker on camera. Let me tell you something and I'll tell you this about campaigning also.
I mean, I love campaigning. I say that campaigning, you meet the angels walking among us like people who, who are just quietly doing really great things without any requirement of fame or notoriety. Thank you. Good, good people. And I mean, that's what, back to the earlier point, that's what gives me my optimism. We can't let the bad guys ruin the day, right? There are so many good, wonderful, incredible people.
And it is they who, you know, motivate me and listening to their stories, if I see them at the grocery store or wherever, that also motivates me. Jason, because you, you take it for you weren't going to fight with a paparazzi guy outside of the Rolls Royce dealership and I can get that for you was a seminal moment. Yeah. Well, he was getting in the reflection. I was trying to really check out the paint and I'm like, buddy, I can't, all right, here's a real hard, hard hitting series of questions.
Okay. Candle or incense? Candle. Oh. Football or basketball? Basketball. Fleetwood Mac or Steely Dan? Steely Dan.
Very nice choice. Have you wondered Marvin Gaye? Oh, I can't do that. Dogs or cats? Dogs. Skying or surfing? Um, I could, you know, probably surfing. Uh-huh.
Sean Hayes or Will Ornette? I can't say. That's really difficult. You can hold that till the end of the interview. That's really difficult. Because right now I think they both have won a series of rounds. Blink once if it's me. Clippers or Lakers?
Warriors. Thank you. Exactly. Yeah. Of course. Well, so A's or Giants? That's hard for me. I mean Giants, but A's, you know, I was born in Oakland.
Yeah. I know. It's tough. You're not a Nationals fan yet, are you? I think one should be loyal to one's team. What in the world do you do for fun? Because like, is it nonstop 24 hours a day doing what you're doing? I love to cook.
But specifically, don't say boiling pasta. I mean, no, everything, you know, I'm always kind of exploring new recipes, but you know, I mean, my go-to, I can do like a great roast chicken or there's a bolognese that I make for four hours that I cook for four hours. So it's a full range. Now is this something that you kind of learned during COVID, you like took some cooking classes or is it something you've, your whole life you loved? My whole life.
My mother was a great cook and I just kind of learned it her, you know, by her side. Oh, I love to cook. I love to cook. Will makes a mean frozen pizza. Sean likes to cook too. Sorry. I mean, Sean likes to talk to cook and he'll say, hey, can you make me, hey, can you cook? Well, you know, if that's it, my mother, my mother, when I was very young, she was like,
kid, you like to eat good food, you better learn how to cook. Oh, man, I wish we had cooking in my house. My mother's British. So, you know, there, there's not a long list of great cooks coming out of that, that country. So I'm still trying to get the boiling pasta stuff down. That's hard for me. Yeah. Also, Jason said the same thing verbatim to his therapist like two hours ago.
Yeah. Yeah. No, this is, this is why I have a lot of those frozen pizza. But Amanda cooks though, doesn't she? Well, we don't, we don't do a lot. We just sort of just go around and kind of pick things out of our kid's hair. So. Wait, Kamala, do you and Doug cook together?
Yeah, Doug is my sous chef. And so we got to the point where I was like, honey, you should just like master three different things and then just make those all the time. And so that's kind of where we are. And I gave him that advice that one time that he was cooking and I was under the fire alarm fanning with my briefing documents for like five minutes, just like, we got to figure out a different process. I see a reality show in your future.
I love it. Can I ask you a question? So let's, you know, let's all hope that, that, that Joe wins Joe Biden wins in November. And I really hope that you're a big part of that. And can you just make me, can you make me a promise right now that, that if that happens as a Canadian, that you'll reach out to the Canadians and say, Hey, listen, I'm sorry. I know we've been a little abusive lately, but we still love you and we'd love to be because you're our closest, you're our biggest trading partner.
You're our closest friend because Canadians feel very like we got, ow, like got kicked in the shin by the big brother. What part of Canada? I'm from Toronto. My aunt lives in Toronto. She lives in Mississauga. No. Yeah.
I'm going to get her number and I'm going to go see her next time I'm up there. I'm going to go see her. We cannot thank you enough for, for joining us truly, really, really knocked us out with your guests. It's great to be with you guys. Thank you. What an honor. Yeah.
Awesome to meet you. Thank you. I'm a huge fan of all of your work. So thank you. Right back at you. Yeah. Thank you. Go get them, Kamala.
Thank you very, very, very much. I'll see you guys next time. Thank you so much. Be well. Bye. Bye. Have a great day. Bye.
Who is that? I don't know. I recognize it from your profile, but that's straight on. By the way, this is the first interview I think you've done without snacking and I think your outfit's a little bit better too and everything. No, I mean. You don't want to be ambassador. You're running for ambassador.
You want to be the ambassador to Canada? I would love to. I mean, or is it available? By the way, could I be? I think I could be. Couldn't I? No, you couldn't be. Why?
Hey, so, guys. Wait, wait, don't, don't just rule it out like, no, you could, both of you and you would sit down. Yeah. You could be better. Don't confuse can't with shouldn't. Yeah. It's a lot of daylight between you and a good choice.
Okay. Hey, so how about, how great is she? I mean, she's just outstanding. Yeah. Well, it was another great episode, Dan, and she was great, amazing person in Jason. Yeah, great. I love her. Honestly, as hard as it is for me to say kudos.
Kudos. Kudos. What does that mean? Great job. That was an awesome, well done. You spell it K or C. C-U-D-O-S. You never heard of kudos? Yeah, I have.
Yeah, no, that was a, I don't understand how we booked her, but she must, she must think you guys are great. I suppose. Anyway, what an episode. Love you guys. Love you too. Hey, listen, can I be the first to say bae? Bae.
Oh. Smart. What? Smart. What? Smart. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.